"The Suicide Squad" is an
awesome, scary, hilarious,
badass, and ultimately heartwarming movie.
It's also a pretty straightforward story,
one whose loose ends get wrapped up
pretty thoroughly. Well, most of the
loose ends. Here are some of the biggest
unanswered questions in "The Suicide Squad."
The first action scene of the movie sees
part of Task Force X land in the
water and set up for a beach assault.
Blackguard walks out first and reveals
that he sold everyone out to the hostiles,
completely blowing everyone's cover and plan.
He then promptly gets his face blown off for
his troubles and kicks off a firefight
that kills almost everyone on the beach.
This raises the first unanswered question of the
movie: How could he have possibly reached them
while locked up? He's in a heavy security prison,
likely being monitored for much of the day.
How did he find his way around this, especially
in the short amount of time between getting his
assignment and deployment, and contacting
the soldiers in Corto Maltese? Seeing as
he's the first death of the movie, it's
unlikely we'll ever get the true story.
This goes hand in hand with the question
of how Blackguard betrayed everyone.
Though she's an expert at appearances,
Amanda Waller doesn't know everything about
everybody. She was, after all, completely
blindsided by Bloodsport's fear of rats —
"I'm not shaking the rat's hand."
— and seemingly didn't know that Blackguard
was going to blow everyone's cover immediately.
But it's hard not to wonder if she saw this
group, which she noted was a diversion,
as even more disposable than the
average Task Force X operation.
This is a pretty pathetic group of heroes. Weasel
drowns almost immediately, but it's hard to say
what Weasel could have contributed under the best
of circumstances. Harley is a fan favorite, but
"audience popularity" doesn't make up for the fact
that she doesn't have many skills that would help
in a firefight -- and she survived largely by dumb
luck. TDK is particularly pathetic, only using his
detachable arms to lightly slap his opponents.
Characters occasionally remark that they didn't
pick the team, which is true -- Waller did,
and she's willing to sacrifice anything and
anyone to get what she wants. Did this group just
have bad luck, or were they always cannon fodder?
This is one question we know is going
to get some kind of an answer, and we've known for
some time. Bloodsport shot Peacemaker in the neck
and left him to bleed out in the rubble. That's
about as certain a killshot as one can get.
"Nothing like a bloodbath to start the day!"
Yet the post-credits scene shows Peacemaker
in a hospital, and Waller's underlings
saying that he'll help save the world.
This is all setting up for the HBO Max
"Peacemaker" series, so there's a near 100%
chance that we'll either see or hear about his
rescue and survival. Even so ... a shot to the
neck is a shot to the neck. He may be a fighter,
but that's a hard thing to overcome -- especially
from one of Bloodsport's proprietary bullets.
We'll just have to wait and see on this one.
Either way, it just shows what wrestling fans
have known for years: John Cena never gives up,
and recovers from injury at miraculous speed.
Let's see if Peacemaker can win the Royal Rumble.
"Is this thing a dog?"
Weasel is the definition of a throwaway character.
In fact, Weasel is several different kinds of
throwaway. He drowns pretty much right away,
with his meaningless death helping set the
movie's comic and violent sensibilities.
But he's also a literal throwaway character,
as in he was thrown away, out of a helicopter.
But wait! A post-credits scene reveals that
Weasel survived! He coughs up some water and
wanders into the woods, seemingly oblivious
to everything that transpired. Now what?
Seriously, though, what happens now? Will we
ever see Weasel again? Did Weasel get immunity
due to Bloodsport's deal with Waller, or was he
exempt since he knows nothing of the hard drive?
Will Weasel become the Bigfoot of Corto Maltese?
There's so many unanswered questions here,
certainly enough to justify a short on HBO
Max -- or at least some bonkers fanfic.
The possibilities for more Weasel are endless.
Amanda Waller is a dangerous person to be
associated with under any circumstances. If
you're her enemy, you're probably going to
die. If you're her ally, she could turn on you the
moment you're no longer useful -- at which point,
she doesn't care if you live or die. Even if
you're a loyal employee, you might end up in
the wrong place at the wrong time and -- as
her team in the first "Suicide Squad' movie
learned -- she'll probably kill you herself.
Given that she once executed her own team
entirely because they accidentally ended
up in a mission they weren't cleared for,
it's easy to see why people fear her. As such,
it took an incomprehensible amount of courage
for her team to literally knock her out and let
Task Force X save the day here. The question is,
will she let that violent insubordination stand?
The movie ends after Starro is defeated and
Bloodsport makes his deal with Waller. What her
team knows of the deal is uncertain. What does
matter is that they struck one of the most
dangerous and vindictive people on Earth in
the head, and it's hard to see them getting away
with that. Even if she's not going to kill them,
she certainly has other ways of
making their lives hell -- and
it's unlikely they'll get off scot free.
Check out one of our newest videos right
here! Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite summer blockbusters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.